got the party doesn't party coming up  Friday I'm going over there old days  let's forget the bud that butt is dead  we got a new dance we just needed a way  you can tell you I I think I see fresh  Fritz after the day let's do that I  think what do you laughing mommy ain't  do it man you Stewart my daddy taught in  there knocking Ella buddy coma  my dad's guitar Mitch are you ready  looks gorgeous little smile look  everybody shoot it I can't end it well  that's not gonna work like us this now  you're gonna get eyes hey what you all  do par go do the wiggle the wiggle I'm  telling you give me dance then she goes  oh my can wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle  wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle  Oh what see it are you doing this yeah  just do it man hey wiggle wiggle wiggle  wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle  what the man you crazy I stick over my  old a wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle  wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle